hey everyone Dave Hollow here and today
we are back with that Fujimoto goodness
and for the second time throughout the
entire story so far we are gifted with
the blessing that is a primal devil in
the flesh this Arc is freaking fantastic
and exemplifies in my opinion why
tatsuki Fujimoto is a god-ti mangaka
with a storytelling prowess only a few
others can even hope to attain this
falling devil Arc picks up perfectly
from where we lift off in the dating
dingy Arc there we saw ASA and dng have
what I would consider to be their first
proper interaction throughout the manga
like I know they have beforehand but it
just wasn't as long as that section
funnily enough that all kind of
backfired though and US ended up
supposedly having her heart broken at
the very end of it if you have missed
that vid and like do want to catch back
up before you get into the falling devil
Arc right here then go and paper it as
you know there are things that get
discussed that do matter for this Arc
right here by the way sit back and relax
subscribe and push this video to 5K
likes so I know you want more and let's
get into this Primal Fear cooking inside
of the devil Hunter club we find ASA and
Yoshida talking about dingy's love life
over tea which I guess is a change in
events from what we just aired as USA
gets served some tea by chainsaw man's
Brave pit she's reminded of the
cringe-worthy moment which she got
rejected by him after yoru randomly
asked him out she knows that he's with
dingy a lot and apparently he's a public
safety devil Hunter despite still being
in school he has to be extremely busy so
to her it makes no sense for him to
spend his time with a loner like her she
wonders if he started noticing her after
she asked him out but ending her
thoughts you should have just questions
what us a Mumble to herself outside of
this school Gates wanting to chat user
expresses her thoughts on how life is
more manageable when one is alone to her
surprise yoshido actually agrees and
mentioned that living with someone else
might make things simpler though there's
no Assurance of a lasting harmonious
relationship Yoshida also concludes on
how these days with books and TV one can
easily have a one-sided parasocial
relationship I like some of my viewers
it's simple this it's simple the
solitary life is less risky and you know
I'm not gonna lie when I sit in my
content cage all day and make videos the
solitary life can be pretty good
sometimes I get where else is coming
from I should get shocked at how you
shoot it affirms her values so she
quickly jumps to the conclusion that
Yoshida could actually have feelings for
her after a while your shooter gets
happy to be on the same page as USA
however he does know that there's
something he's been meaning to tell her
Sigma Yoshida Bliss his soul and like
not even realizing their turbulent set
of emotions USA is currently going
through over this exact scenario tells
her to stay away from dingy confused by
the statement Isa proceeds to ask for
the reason but Yoshida is rigid or not
telling her and wants USA to interpret
it however she likes just as abruptly as
he showed up Yoshida then leaves the
office watching USA to have a good day
skipping over to the wet dog smelling
apartment now you just smells something
nasty to her as the nastiest smell she's
ever smelled sitting up she commands
denji to go chainsaw man as it's time to
start hunting some devils laying amongst
the dogs on the floor though dingy just
reveals how he doesn't like being a
chainsaw man anymore nausic tries to
motivate him by saying that she wants to
see him fight but didn't you believes
that even if everybody finds out he's
chainsaw man nobody's going to like him
as neuter will just end up blocking
dingy from getting his ends overwhelmed
with it all didn't you just wonders if
he's going to stay single forever naota
Still A New Path for war is absolutely
convinced that if our boy dingy
transforms into chainsaw man he'll
become an instant hit with the masses
and receive way way more love than any
girlfriend could ever offer him it's so
bad but she's like denji's manipulative
motivational coach and with her delicate
little pep talks even El lazy dingy who
still hasn't even moved yet from the
floor gets hyped and ready to roll after
a while and having left this school of
self ASA starts overthinking like most
of us do in real life she thinks to
herself on how a life of solitude would
really be better than feeling
overwhelmed like this she's quick to
convince herself someone likes her and
when she's wrong it breaks her heart
stooping lower and lower to the ground
are surprised deeply causing yodu to
show up and agree with the thoughts that
she's been having ASA believes that she
only cares about herself and whenever
she gets lonely she craves a companion
judu thinks that Asura's pain a little
too hard on herself while also
hilariously agreeing to the fact that
asur is a is a little bit arrogant not
listening to her though I suggest
Wonders that she's better off dead
suddenly though A man was distorted and
twisted limbs drops down right next to
the path she was just walking on looking
at him she can't help but notice the
agonizing look of pain in his eyes
instantly yodu tears her way forth and
takes control of Us's body exclaiming
that there's something wrong in front of
her has shown that every resident inside
of her building has walked out onto
their veranda and is now staring
directly at her elsewhere and I guess
while on a little date with Yoshida
family has been given a huge portion of
desserts funnily enough it's the exact
same Cafe that Yoshida had previously
brought dingy to sitting there Yoshida
States it you know he expected her to
hold back at the aquarium and another
twist it's revealed that it was actually
Yoshida who initially invited Fami out
to mate so the whole situation fell on
him taken aback by the statement Yoshida
shares how we never actually expected
femi Senpai to show up or should he say
the famine devil to show up he also
reveals that he came across a rumor that
devils are bad with names so when Alias
is Boulder's family makes it obvious in
his eyes that she really wasn't even
trying to hide Hertz sticking with like
not even caring femur reveals that she
has no intention of hiding her own
identity and instead just asks what he
wants with her so could all Yoshida
following up a Roma with another Roma
but he goes in depth on an urban legend
going around town this Legend originates
from the prophecy of Nostradamus who
predicted that in the seventh month of
1999 a great king of Terror will descend
society's perception of the urban legend
though was nothing more than a
sensationalized TV or cable bars that
have been swirling around exciting
students however the public safety
organization believes otherwise back
earlier 1999 to carry out a specific
experiment 30 convicts were presented
with an intriguing opportunity to make
contracts for the future of evil they
promised their release from captivity
afterwards but there was a catch they
had to inquire about the timing of their
own demise the result of the steering
experiments were both astonishing and
chilling it was determined that the
future devil seemingly predicted a grim
fate for a significant portion of
participants a staggering 23 out of the
30 convex were predicted to meet the end
in the ominous month of July 1999. not
really bothered by this information femi
just questions her statement so your
[__] isn't a little bit of a dilemma
here he's desperately trying to get
family this building beams he knows
she's up to something but the public
safety orb believes it's connected to
the prophecies the only reason Yoshida
even came to this Cafe was to talk so if
she's gonna sit there and refuse it may
only leave him worth unleashing the not
so pretty devil treatment but hey femi
doesn't want any hands with our man and
finally opens up she asks if the the
other seven were also fated to die this
week and that just 40 seconds ago a
devil decided to pop into existence at
the East District terminal Apartments so
yeah shit's about hit the fan and unlike
literally anything else we've seen so
far in this series this is the first
evil who will ship at the wield until
ultimate Terror then his family proceeds
to state that this devil is one with the
name of a primal fear and skips back to
where we were just before with USA and
the falling body however the whole
environment suddenly changes instead of
outside now we're in with a cute
middle-aged couple who are in good
spirits over the dude's recent promotion
randomly the dude who was in the middle
of a conversation about how it's
probably not realistic for him to own a
car in the city Tunes towards misses and
asks if she reckons they should just die
twitch the wife who initially looked a
bit sketched out with what he was saying
is like die yeah sure let's go for it a
cute NPC couple will then stroll over to
their front door open it hop over the
railing and jump from their Terrace
falling straight to the ground below
surprisingly it's not just them Indian
lives it's the whole terminal apartment
building with every single person
jumping from their Terrace yodu who was
witnessing this from the ground below
commands a royal sword turning one of
her rulers into a crafty weapon seeing
the creature's arms though and realizing
that this is not a fight she can win
Judo drops her bag and turns in an
attempt to run from the mysterious
multiple limbed devil behind her the
devil picks up one of the jumpers and
uses her head as his own then looking
down at her own body and the appendages
growing from her she realizes just how
indecent she's currently being having
chucked on a chef's outfit she exclaims
that tonight the falling devil shall be
their chef according to her she is
visiting at the request of every
resident inside of Hell elsewhere and
while running ASA temporarily falls for
the devil's negative feelings but yodu
tries to snap her out of it the falling
devil on the other hand introduces her
first course called
like you guys do not understand the
struggle I just went through to say that
anyways anyways suddenly a suited memory
replays on the back of Us's mind it was
during us as childhood more specifically
after the death of her mother and during
the time she spent in an orphanage The
Madame at the orphanage wanted Assa to
give her cat away to one of her family
friends since some of the kids there are
allergic and it was actually unhealthy
for USA to depend on the cat's
companionship instead of interacting
with other people as much ASA didn't
want to let go of her the Madame kept on
forcing her to while giving us her an
example from the kids at the orphanage
and how they don't even have anyone
because the Devils killed their parents
even hers too just like USA the madame's
mother was also taken out by the typhoon
devil mentioning the sad fact
successfully manipulates Assa into
giving up the cat named cranbourne but
only under the condition that it was
going to a family friend later at night
and while in bed us gets asked about her
cats by one of the kids laying right by
her side sadly that same kid reveals
that when she went to play on the river
earlier on there was a cat that looks
exactly like cramboyant the bottom when
the Madame walks in to tell them to
sleep ASA asks if her cat's okay instead
of a straightforward response though the
Madame revealed a painful truth that
left us a speechless each child inside
of the orphanage had suffered a
heart-wrenching loss of their families
leaving him all to face the world
without the love and care of the
appearance so because of this The Madame
seemed to believe that it was utterly
unfair for us to be the only one with a
family member while no one else does an
imprisoned as his mind is consumed by
The Haunting memory of the falling
Devil's dish making her scream out and
heartfelt pain hanging there her
thoughts swirled with a new mind as she
imagines a surreal scene where everyone
around her seems to be slowly falling
into the sky amidst this disturbing
imagery yolu shares her own troubling
Revelation she can't seem to enter Us's
body as she usually does yet even admits
this Darkness a glimmer of hope remains
a judu screams out for USA to not be
afraid while ASA is on the verge of
falling into the darkness yodu tries to
talk her into grabbing the pole tighter
however as it still Falls and obviously
not wanting to die yodu commanded USA to
chant nail knife which in turn detaches
one of Us's nails and turns it into a
small blade due to the pain though the
previous thought she had vanished and it
allowed her to fall to the ground
getting up yodu went to some pain as she
begins walking forth and quietly washes
to herself that USA would concentrate on
her fingers egg hoping that it might act
as a distraction while she keeps her
fear at Bay thinking on the events that
just passed yodu notices what's going on
and that some of the Humans Ain't Even
affected by the devil's ability
pondering what devil it could possibly
be yodu thinks that it's the trauma no
moon no gravity no Kuma side no no no no
no no no it's the kind of devil that
makes your hair stand on its ends the
falling devil curious yodu wonders why
she even appeared here and if she has
any connections with the famine devil
after a while she notices us fear
returning and cuts her hand to make us a
focus on the pain again as his body
takes back over though as she crashes
into the floor reappearing next to her
yodu just asked why she's afraid of her
and keeps driving her out of her body
when all she's doing is trying to keep
them alive and raged at yodu screaming
ASA also explains that she knows nothing
about yodu she takes her over her body
whenever she wants and is always scaring
her yodu believes that it's because
she's afraid but ASA argues again that
it's because she cut her damn hand
standing upside down yodu tries
explaining that the devil's power is
making her feel negative and needs to
think this through logically if they use
yoru's agility they'll survive but her
fear is jeopardizing their current
survival switching with self-doubt now
ASA asks yodu whether she can delve
inside her mind and see the very thing
that she fears the most she understands
that she has trust issues and is pretty
lonely so once in a while approaches
someone still that's when it all goes
wrong for her and in typical fashion she
ends up hurt and alone once more
something always goes wrong resulting in
her getting hurt without even receiving
a reply I suggest state that it's
Solitude and companionship she's afraid
of them both kind of crazy when you
think about that's exactly what she's
caught here with Yahoo she has this
companion who could actually never leave
her but on the same page she's afraid of
even considering this person a companion
and trusting her in poets anyways
anyways bless my French as our current
falling devil who's cooking up some more
hate has just laid out another course
called deroot atalante a cottage made
from the I guess you could say exposed
parts of devil Hunters who tried to take
her out among the Fallen she spared one
fortunate Soul keeping him alive for her
Sinister plans the mess sight of this
horrible creature though since Shivers
across the body of our mute friend as
that bug then chowed down shift falling
let us all know of the main meal that
she intends to serve to those of the
underworld its name Asar route yaru a
human and War devil Fusion suddenly a
whole group of devil Hunters are blinded
and defeated as the Gordon Ramsay of the
devil World flies forth hitting all of
the supplies needed to create another
pottage spotting a nearby AGI
Supermarket the falling Devil Makes Her
Way inside where she looks for a type of
apple that pairs well with all of the
previous basically collected supplies
looking up it's revealed that because
the manager of this store is afraid he's
floating on the ceiling and can now only
apologize in Terror Fallen exclaims that
unless they mean to attack she won't do
them any harm and only needs a few
apples from this store walking out of
the store now falling stops dead in her
tracks as she realizes she's forgotten a
portion of her sauce recipe the falling
devil then reaches the Tomato Apartments
again and yells out for someone to later
use one of their heads but before she
could even figure what's going on a
nearby devil Hunter initiates the Ambush
suddenly a master Sharpshooter opens
fire and shoots at her a multitude of
times finding the current situation just
awkward the full Endeavor revives
yourself and reveals that it's
impossible to kill her so instead of
fighting she prefers to avoid
meaningless Slaughter and just really
needs that ingredient not falling for
these tricks though get it on so
freaking lame the dude shot at it once
more however this time ends in a
fraction of a second she shoots forth a
Sonic Blast that annihilates the entire
building not only does does it take out
all of your competition but she also
manages to get that sought after
ingredient finally allowing her to
create that dank Source All That Remains
to finish creating the perfect meal is
to make USA mitaka fall and then the
dish will be complete that ain't
happening though and his falling hissy
sound of our boy denji shows up already
fully transformed and ready to throw
hands with a so-called Primal Fear
screaming at the Devil dingy accuses
them of a horrendous crime he saw it
just before she is a thief who doesn't
pay for her goddamn apples randomly and
in an instant dingy's body is then
sliced to birds still he ain't done that
easily he manages to hold himself
together as he reverses the situation
and sticks the shift on the menu
grabbing your head and throwing a fat
Kick falling since dingy crashing back
into the side of the building picking up
the food that she just dropped in the
short scuffle she identifies chainsaw
man and reveals that she won't kill any
more humans so there's there's no need
to fight the only thing that's really on
her mind right now is her final task of
dropping usmitaka into hell after that
she'll take you leave here in the woods
ASA and Hell dingy questions this random
foe having fixed up their outfit
tatsuki's personal chef explains that
she was given a job it's simple she just
has to feed the residents of hell and
asimitarka is the final course Digi
explains aloud that nothing she says
makes any sense but this is great now as
he has a reason to actually kill her
flying forth he screams for her to keep
their hands off his ex-potential pearl
friend curious about how badly dingy
could sub for someone falling just
casually stops him with one finger while
stating that he's impeding with her
cooking so he has to leave confused
dingy watches as the devil sticks out
one of her hands and commands him to
fall all of a sudden Genji's chainsaw
form vanishes and he sees a bunch of
terrible memories from his past that
cause him to scream out in pain in
reality and like everyone else affected
by the devil's Powers dingy and his
chainsaw man form had begun helplessly
falling upwards making or leave now the
falling devil turns to try and track
down us Ascend taken by complete
surprise though then he doesn't give up
and somehow manages to slow was the
falling devil in half utterly
flabbergasted didn't she explains that
every devil he fights uses mental
attacks well he just cuts up his brain
as a role to fix it walking forth while
muttering that he wants to eat corn dogs
specifically corn dogs from France Digi
leans down and physically begins to eat
the devil's leg while still
simultaneously slicing his own head to
stop the mental attacks and the ship's
body to keep her immobilized having
screamed that she wasn't a corn dog
falling soon starts questioning of
perhaps what dengie's doing might be
right as she thought to experience being
eaten at least once once allowing
herself to be completely devoured by the
chainsaw devil Falling re-emerges by
exploding out of Genji's stomach fully
revived and thanking him for the
five-star experience but just like
before she needs to go and return to her
cooking nothing actually makes sense in
my life anymore and with dingy somehow
hanging on he plunges his chainsaw
straight through the side of the devil's
head in an attempt to stop her still
falling really isn't phased by any of
this and just raises her hand to flick
Genji off onto the ground looking at
this pathetic state she just remarks
that she detests ugliness turning around
and making her leave now the falling
devil Glides up into the sky to track
down us as scent lift on the ground
writhing in pain dingy screams out for
them to get back randomly though someone
with a familiar pair of shoes shows up
right next to him I'm not 100 caught up
here to like the current chapter or
anything so I don't know if this was
revealed on who it might be but in my
head Canon right now this is 100 kabani
obviously correct me if I'm wrong it's
just those shoes just they look like the
devil under shoes and something can
beanie would 100 wear plus you know like
what I see next in her hand and
everything anyways anyways sticking out
their hand and making a small incision
the random devil Hunter revives chainsaw
man and proclaims that they still need
him to fight meanwhile the full interval
floats her way across town towards Us
location after spotting the scared high
schooler ASA screams in panic that it's
finally found them using the power of
falling falling Flex her finger to make
the building as it was on break apart
managing to just grab onto the railing
ASA and Yodo could only watch as the
falling evil places both of your hands
on each side of her head holding the
absolutely terrified High School of the
year the Primal Fear reveals that Us's
attachment to life is weak to begin with
in fact what truly scares her is the
shock of impact the physical sensation
of falling and how this Sky will slowly
Fade to Black wide-eyed and unable to do
anything falling just tells her to close
her eyes as she can promise her a
peaceful descent yodu on the other hand
panics knowing the inevitable war is
about to occur looking away from her as
it gets reminded of all of the trauma
that she has faced earlier in life and
because of that sadly closes her
sweat-filled eyes letting go of
everything ASA falls through the
darkness and thanks to herself that it
is really true she feels at PACE now
promising upwards Towards the Sky she
knows that now she won't have to cause
trouble for anyone else or could do
feelings hurt anymore she won't have to
lie in beard thinking about all of the
things she did wrong however she does
have one regret even if it was worth
only one person should have loved
wholeheartedly all of a sudden though
denji makes a super cool dope
spectacular super awesome entrance and
saves Asa from falling by holding the
building's railings and not letting her
float off also of course it's literally
as she was about to finish saying that
she wished she had someone to love
surprisingly ASA who realizes that
chainsaw man of all people saved her
tells him to wait and let go of her she
is perfectly okay with falling she's
accepted her fate now looking at her and
wondering if she's gone mad I said just
screams that life is nothing but pain
always getting made of full of getting
hopes up constantly only to be let down
every single damn time hearing her out
then she actually agrees with what she's
spinning causing himself to be sucked up
into the air as well figuring out the
effects of falling's ability as
explained that the worse you feel the
heavier you get but upwards trying to
get her to think of like happy thoughts
Genji just screams dogs and cats dogs
and cats until Usher eventually comes to
a complete standstill on this scott-hire
noticing that they've stopped now I have
slowly begins to open her teary eyes not
happy with the levels of manipulation
dingy just went to though she tells him
to not make her remember cats but he
tries to get it across to her that he
understands the situation she's in he's
been in a similar one himself she just
has to believe him letting out I suggest
a mind her to know what in the world
he'd know not a single damn person has a
worse life than herself looking into her
eyes he confesses that just when life
seems super awesome as soon as you let
your guard down then something super
crappy happens out of nowhere and it
screws everything up all in all though
life really isn't that bad it's just
that we're wired so day in and day out
all we remember is the bad stuff
mentally their bad stuff then piles up
as if someone's crafting a [__] Burger
of emotions wondering how like the great
chainsaw man was able to overcome these
emotions he replies that he hasn't only
he's got something to live for something
he looks forward to with a ferocity that
not even his own crap Burger of emotions
can hold him back curiously she wonders
what this one one factor is and
screaming it out like the degenerative
child that he is he proclaims that he
wants to bang the idea of it in his eyes
is more than enough to keep on fighting
to live for making ASA immediately
cringe with pure disgust in fact she
finds dingy creepy telling him that she
changed her mind and instead wants him
to go to hell as well dingy is like nah
nah nah nah bro this is it it reminds
her on how Humanity got to the size it
is today all because it feels so damn
amazing oh bro I'm so uncomfortable
dingy right now I can just say this out
loud is making me so uncomfortable I
should find stingy gross but he still
keeps on appreciating the beauty of
hooking up also though reminds them
about how people really only hook up
because they have nothing better to do
like surely somebody else's saliva and
sweat or mixing together with yours
that's just like totally gross dingy
though thinks on like completely
opposite poles and finds the process
beautiful what am I actually even
talking about right now I swear to Lord
Fujimoto we were just in the middle of a
fight against a primal fear what are we
doing now anyways anyways after a while
ASA asks stingy what makes him think
he'll get a girlfriend but you see our
boy is absolutely optimistic and he
thinks that when he gets older he'll be
able to get one as the screams that no
woman in existence would want to hook up
with a guy who has a chainsaw sticking
out of his head and obviously out of
everything they've said so far the
strikes a certain chord within her boy's
soul and seems I'm hurling upwards
towards the quickly opening door to hell
with the door slamming behind them
putting them now in Hell dinging without
hesitation grabs USA off the plate she
was stationed on spotting another nearby
door dingy tosses ASA up over his
shoulder and heads in that direction
striking through the darkness tentacled
like appendages strikered our main man
as he rushes forth trying to make it to
the doorway instantly appearing behind
him an unnamed devil slices dingy up
sitting his head soaring across the room
but not before he quickly grabs his own
head and reattaches it while starting
his engines finally making it to the
perfectly placed doorway then she opens
it just to see the falling devil herself
stand in there she explains again that
hurt dish doesn't call for chainsaw man
so all he has to do is leave her and
he'll be sent back safely pulling his
cord and starting that Infamous chainsaw
once more he just questions if it's
possible to just bring back us as rear
end which is just crazy dude and feeling
the degeneracy also oozing from this man
falling calls him an utter pervert
randomly someone equipped with chainsaws
burst through the falling devil from
behind completely destroying her body
and making her a Mark that this
annoyance keeps happening to her today
walking through the door this person
knows that the falling devil doesn't
have a tolerance for diners who leave
their food unfinished everyone inside of
Hell will desperately try and devour our
sir otherwise their lives are at rest as
well without ever revealing who this
random chainsaw man figure is they just
tell our chainsaw man to please keep
evading those hordes until sunrise
waking up and looking at the figure in
the doorway USA just thinks to herself
why these two chainsaw mans instantly
some massive appendages push both dingy
and ASA Out of Hell back into the real
world yodu realizes is the situation
that they're in with like chainsmen
lying knocked out on the floor there and
asks us to finish him off while he's
down in fact if she kills him right now
then yodu will return her body back to
her and she'll finally be normal again
one scene in pain though you can't seem
to get a grasp on us as emotions just
when she thought she'd begun to
understand her she always does the
opposite of what she says grabbing a
rock and bashing her hand and I
suppresses her hand above chainsaw man's
mouth in an attempt to revive him with
his blood yodu screams that she doesn't
need to take it as far as literally
saving her mortal enemy but Usher
explains that during the fight with Yuko
and even earlier today chainsaw man had
saved her life twice now plus watching
chainsaw man had made a thing that even
if a loser like him is allowed to
somehow keep on living then maybe it's
okay for her to live too a fraction of a
second later a sharply spiked tendul
shot out of the door the group had just
escaped through but just in time she was
able to pull denji's cord and say those
prolific words save me chainsaw man
instantly denji fully revived dart's
fourth with Usher in his hands and lands
on a nearby car not even giving them a
moment of rest those same tendrils
destroy the car forcing the duo to try
and move between a multitude of
buildings as they continue to dodge the
tendrils DJ began to tire from all of
the jumping he confessed to us sir that
he was getting exhausted and might not
even be able to save her heading to the
impending Dome 10 or so more tendrils
than bursts through every surrounding
building leaving the duo with no Escape
at all somehow escaping though like I'm
I'm mentally confused on how dingy even
managed to evade that last strike
someone actually helped me down in the
comment section below anyways anyways as
you once again reiterates just how tired
he is Usher spot some check on her
motorbike and tries getting him to steal
it as an option not stupid and the
slightest though dingy notes that he
can't steal that bike a woman's riding
it quickly picking the next option Asura
is like still that guy's then and
without a fraction of hesitation Genji
kicks the man off the bike on top of
that and as dingy sat there chilling on
the bike man was like don't play me to
the owner blame this chick behind me
before suddenly realizing that his
angels were hidden directly at him and
he can't even drive a bike to begin with
not having any other option as a screams
out super chainsaw man motorcycle and at
the exact same time the tendulum slams
down on the duo however our team emerges
Victorious as Us's Powers turn the bike
into a massive moving chainsaw that
shreddedly tendul to birds guessing it
through the streets now dingy looks down
to see that the bike turned all badass
and just assumes that it was probably a
power he didn't even know he had I said
notes that the fake chainsaw man said if
they outrun all of their tendrils then
they will survive all of a sudden this
sky darkens as above a plethora of those
same tendrils gather ready to Pound Down
on their fleeing Duo as the ground is
destroyed it's shown that somehow dingy
managed to manipulate the bike's
polarity and was able to dodge the
attack by driving across the side of a
nearby apartment back in Hell the
tendril or whatever devil this is that's
controlling these things back on Earth
but really face palms and frustration
over what he's witnessing then merging
into one of his own tentacles the
creature proceeds to try and slam down
on dingy and usur but luckily our men's
bike skills are simply unbelievable and
it was able to skirt off this side of
the building then boost it through the
Straits as the massive devil chased
after them dingy wonders what in the
freaking world is that thing but before
he even has time to think about it ASA
points out the literal skyscraper that
had been floated above them by the
falling devil commanding him to eat it
the falling devil drops the entire
building completely destroying the
entire area inside of the collapsing
structure our man still riding at full
speed manages to drive up and out the
other side before there were two almost
swallowed by the rubble sadly for them
though the massive devil had already
predicted this insane movement path and
placed himself in a perfect position to
swallow falling Riders as dingy and ASA
are heading towards the unknown Devil's
Mouth then she tries to steer them out
of the way only for the falling devil to
remark that food shouldn't be able to
run before sending them with her ability
into the mouth of the devil while the
devil chowing down she asks how the
taste of a human steeped in fear tastes
like seeing the pained look on its face
the devil instantly vomits regurgitating
both ASA and dingy crying tears of blood
and gradually becoming more and more
annoyed they fall into Old yells at the
other one claiming that she made a meal
with love so how dare throw it up before
pointing her finger forth and executing
it with a blast of energy hidden away
from the wreckage he falling devil bows
while apologizing to Fami revealing that
they plan for ASA to be consumed was he
let his idea femi who doesn't seem like
too paved over the entire ordeal orders
her to return to Hell causing the
falling devil to explode and burst into
flames as the devil Burns it gradually
becomes smaller until they Point their
family is able to reach out with one
hand and grab herbs even more basale
naota is also revealed to be prisoned
with femi noting that she was the one
that caused the devil to actually throw
up speaking of herself now NATO explains
that she controlled the devil's brain
just a just a Teensy bit and made any
human at a taste like actual crab
curiously new to us swahil's sister is
targeting ASA and dingy twitch femi
reveals that nostradamus's prophecy is
going to come true and the ultimate
Terror will soon descend upon this world
if that happens the age of humanity will
end ushering in an age of devils
initially naota seems to be like totally
on board with that idea thinking that it
kind of sounds fun however Demi states
that if an age of devils does come
things like pizza and delectable Chinese
foods will cease to exist making Ayo to
scorn at the idea that Peter would no
longer exist and both sister's eyes it's
literally like the worst case scenario
imaginable sadly at the current strength
everyone is on not a single soul in
their group will be able to stop the
prophecy family remarks that whilst the
prophecy itself will come true
regardless of what they do she does
believe that they could make the war
devil win instead naoto points out how
stupid that sounds as she just tried to
have USA consumed a moment ago to which
femi says that she only did it in order
to starve the war devil as she is able
to control those who are experiencing
hunger with all of that said she offers
naos in an alliance since with the
combined strength the age of devils may
not arrive but naotao denies it since
she's got to go to school instead
flashing into school then the teacher
asks for them to raise their hands if
they know the answer and without
hesitation the class including naota who
obviously got her way throws up her hand
so boom that there brings us to the end
of the falling devil Arc which was
something else entirely from tatsuki's
writings like I don't think he's been
this this manic this crazy with it
before like I I was giggling so hard
while recording this at some points I
just had to stop and actually re-record
some parts of it anyway I'm actually
like kind of curious as to what role now
to fully play throughout the arc that we
just witnessed might just be my marking
my PTSD but seeing any form of stomach
chain connected to den she makes me
absolutely curious and there was like a
few moments throughout this Arc here
where I saw like some bit of dingy
stomach going off elsewhere and I'm like
hmm was he getting controlled or was
this just like I don't know I was he
just healing up or something you know
anyways if you guys did enjoy the
falling devil Arc then be sure to leave
a like and push this video to 5K likes
as it shows that you want more of like
my chainsaw man content if you are
interested in that make sure you do
subscribe to keep up to date with the
plethora of different Series going
towards 200k almost there like what only
like 30k to 200k slabs now which is
crazy but anyway for now to be in your
professional degenerate follow and I
will see you all enabled bye